okay thank you sonalika and um
omics logic group for inviting me
and uh welcome to all the participants
and uh i will give you a myself sanji
and i'm the director in biocos life
sciences we do a lot of computations
and a lot of research in computational
biology genomics basically and we are
based in bangalore about 13 years old
company
so with that i will
introduce you with very basic single
cell and special transcriptomics and
other data types
so let me start
so
this is the presentation flow
let me check my pen is working
yes
fine
so this will be the presentation flow i
will give you ngs in journal because
many steps overlap with even single cell
so i will make a background quickly
and 8 to 10 minutes then i will tell you
single cell what yn methods and analysis
[Music]
fine
and then single cell transcriptome
uh basically single cell rna sequencing
and then a spatial single cell i will
give you the basics
and i will also try to get to the very
you know on new ones in the field with
the very tentative layman kind of
explanations how it is then single cell
epig epigenetics
basically atac sec
which is basically adapted from the bulk
epigenetics protocols to the
single cell then i will drive time
permits to run some of the tools and
give you demo and tell about them
so in basic when we are talking about
ngs
uh if you see the history for singer
methods and somewhere dna microarrays
some of us we have very
widely worked on them
[Music]
and
that was the very high throughput first
time
and then after that the field was
revolutionized by illumina sort
um sequencing which came somewhere
around 2008
then now we are on the single molecule
sequencing and single cell
which is the third generation
now if you see here various protocols
uh if you see here these are all dna
and there are decides rna protocols so
we can analyze a lot of
like variants
then targeted like exome amplicons
and then we have basically epigenetics
protocol single cell and a lot of rna
transcriptomics and targeted rna and
small rnas
so if we look at
the whole
bunch of analysis required for the
genetics now if you see this is
basically a epi genetics block here
which is in red so if you see mostly
these are the regulatory elements like
mnesec
then dna spirit sex
chipset
and then
occupancy of
you know dna which is adac sec
which is basically
assays with transposes accessible
chromatin what is accessible and if you
see this side basically this blue side
this is basically
the transcriptome
rna-seq so
and you can see the transcripts variants
and mutations
so with the now invent of these ngs
protocols
we can analyze the whole spectrum of
dna from epigenetics changes to
regulatory changes and transcriptome
now there are hundreds
in fact more than hundreds of protocols
now if you see here this is basically
dominated by gene expression any biology
in genome regulation but you see a lot
of small small new protocols like
including single cells they are coming
up
so
there are so many protocols are coming
which use which are using ngs
now if we see at the ngs flow basically
it is
uh three steps prepare your library
sequence and then analyze
so it depends what is your
biological material
and which you are trying to address
so it can be single cell or it can be a
bulk
and the protocol
first extract the dna then library
refresh preparation matters on what is
your
biology question and what is your
material like single cell or bulk or rna
or gypsy then you amplify it
and then sequence
like elimina
or
miser and once it is sequenced the raw
image comes and then one then after that
the read comes
here
and these reads are aligned to the
reference genome
here
and once they are in alive and aligned
then down the line when you are
analyzing then you can see various
you know protocol depending on your
analysis rnac transcriptome or variants
or protein dna interaction epigenetics
can you can infer and then downstream
analysis like networks and all kind of
things can be done
so basically this is the ngs flow
and this is a common flow most of the
protocols
including single cell or
so these are the sequencer i'm just
rushing through the briefly uh you may
be knowing all these things like
illumina everybody's nose
uh specific biosciences long reeds
oxford nano
four which is also long read and there
are three types actually sort read long
read and direct read has come
so
these are the three types of sequencing
mechanisms
now the what is the basic philosophy you
take the fragments so these are the
fragments and they are breaking
they are broken
and then they are sequenced
and once you sequence the these are
called reads and you get the reeds
now these reeds
here you can see they are barcoded
basically index
uh here in bulk
you know rna or chipseek they are
basically to decipher the samples you
can run in together and then later you
can demultiplex so this is basically but
later you will see in single cell
we will see
we will need different kind of tags
so once it is tagged
then you have the read you can sequence
from the one end or you can sequence
from the both the end so this is your
fragment
which was fragmented and amplified in
pcr so you can take a single entry or
you can take both the ends so you get
the pair end leads
and this part basically is not sequenced
that's that's the way the these ngs
protocols win over sanger sequencing
because you don't have to sequence from
one end to other and it's statistically
because you have millions or millions of
reads so they
cover whole genome that's the idea
whether we are
winning over cost winning over time
now once you have sequenced either both
ends or single length then you get this
faster q file
once you get a faster q file which is
basically the four lines so this is your
read
one end or both end if it is both end
two files will get one in
read one and the e2 and then you have
the quality once you have the quality
which is spread quality check it and it
has to be above 30 and nowadays
sequences are very much good so even
people are taking 40 it depends on your
protocol like variance it has to be
higher depth and better quality
in chipseek you can survive with the
lesser one
so once you once we have got the faster
queue and with better quality
then the next one is we align to the
reference genome this is your reference
and this reads are aligned to the
reference and once it is aligned you can
compare like here you can see the
variance so once they are compared then
we can analyze variants or other
protocols the other protocols are like i
have told you the variant detection so
you see the statistically how much is
the coverage and with statistically how
much is the p value then you can see
whether g's variant a is there here or
not
this is basically your variant detection
the other one is the rnac this is the
bulk one then you have a sample one in
sample two as you know this is the
digital compared to the fluorescence
microarray so here you see the pile say
for example these are the 20 and the
sample two this is say three so now if
you see this is gene one
so this gene one here
you can see is the expressed in sample 1
but it is not in sample 2
right
so
based on the p value so you can detect
rna sec
this is
transcriptome the expression gene
expression
and then in chipset more than count we
are bothered about the pattern if it is
a pattern then it means the protein is
binding on a dna as you know the
transcription factors in it how the
protein interacts with dna is very much
analyzed using the chipset
so the vc the pattern so basically these
three kind of protocols are
mainly the applications of ngs but
they're in bulk
now as i go to the single cell before
that let me tell you the what is the
mrna or rna set this is the bulk one
just
uh to give you the background so you
have a sample of interest
disease tumor or something then you have
rna molecules they are fragmented then
here you see they are basically adapters
are added they are the barcodes and then
when you sequence so you have a read one
and e2 and then you have the adapters
and once you remove these adapters so
you can get read one and this is read
two which are aligned to the genome and
there are some complexities when you
align on the you know because
uh cdna when taken from
rna mrna there are the breaks which are
introns are spliced out in that that i'm
not going to discuss once it is aligned
and
then we can do the data analysis like
dsec2
then hd count and various other methods
li mine all kind of things so you can
use differential expression variant
calling annotations and novel
transcripts and editing
now
with this background i have covered very
quickly the ngs uh protocols now we are
going to go to single cell now that's
what we are um today's uh
talk
so i hope you have
you know got the idea what is ngs how it
is different in single cell that will be
we will see so if we look at the layman
type of
analogy suppose this is a kind of a big
game like olympic then you see hundreds
of countries and you know thousands and
thousands of players now how you
evaluate a player performance and how
you identify
so let me say that player is like a cell
so first one is pull a player out
okay so that is isolation
correct
now once you pull a player out
how are you going to analyze it now you
have to tag it first one is you have to
identity that is the player name right
then you have a country which is its
special location
and then what is the action what he has
won that is basically his achievement
expression in some sense you can
analogically you can
compare
that is medals what is his performance
now you need three texts right one two
and three to identify
the player name which is something like
a cell barcode which are nothing but
micro particles beads you might have
heard in single cell there are beads
where there is a cell then you have umi
unique molecular identifiers they are
like a transcript like your rna mrna and
then you have a special location in some
of the sequencing based spatial analysis
so with this you know layman example how
you
infer anything
basically especially in
time access any object in the nature is
something like that so we have to
analyze the cells also like that
now
cells in multiple context as in previous
example i have shown you a one player
now if you see here they are in multiple
dimensions they work like environmental
stimuli like you can see a blue cell
here
so let's see
and it goes in cell development cell
cycle and spatial context like a micro
environment in the tumor progression and
so if you see the cell is not a static
object like earlier we were you know
analyzing so now if you see here that we
are seeing the five dimensions the first
one you have a discrete type you have to
see what kind of cells are there
right
so there may be a rare cell die
the other one is the continuous
phenotype regulatory so they get
inflammatory and that kind of changes
happens to the cell even in
they change their functionality
when they are in a cancer or something
like that and then you have the temporal
at the time changes like stem cells they
differentiate into different kinds so
and then vesilation when they are
revisiting so there are multiple
dimensions then another one
once you have found a discrete types
here the cell types then how you can
map it back to the histological sections
from where they are god
that is basically a special position as
you know it's very important like in
tumor
and
emt and that kind of what kind of
collagens and how they are in matrix how
they are so
even in other contexts it's very
important
so i hope that gives you the background
like how it is important and what kind
of cell multiple contexts are there and
why people are trying to you know like
single cell spatial
and the trajectories and all kind of
things because that's the way in for the
full whole functionality
now
why we need it now if you see here as
you see adipose tissues they are made up
of different type of cells
so
almost everywhere you will find tissues
and organs they are very different types
of cells they are made up of and they
interact
so then you have it not peripheral blood
that is now if you see on this now
if you take an average here
none of the cell is
basically depicted their behavior
as a wider
by the averaging
that's why we cannot infer that what
kind of
behavior is happening for example let me
tell you a realistic situation we faced
so a few years back
we have a project which was a brain
tissue of mouse so there was a cell
and they were dying basically in that
particular disease and there was so many
cells so let's say these are hundred and
they were say five
so when we analyzed transcriptome so
this basically it was coming because it
was cumulative bulk and because the
cells were individually there
you know individually very high but when
it comes bulk it was coming because
there were hundreds and they were dying
and this was the problem basically and
that time let me tell you we couldn't do
single cell it's a pretty old 2008-10
project
so
that time we realized how to capture
only these cells transcriptome
and today i realized that it was very
important so i hope you understand why
it is needed in such
situations especially brain where the
you know the cells are very much
localized in different areas of the
brain
so
same way in the disease cases you see
you will find a disease specific cells
once you find disease specific cells
then you can infer what kind of you know
you can have the targets or the you know
therapeutic therapeutics but it is
important to decipher what kind of cells
are so the single cell analysis is
enabling nowadays
as it is coming
very much to decipher these kind of
questions which we could not address
now single cell it was earlier also if
we look at the traditional single cell
it was microscopy cytometry now nowadays
it is also there
i'm just rushing through some slides
because i have a lot of things to cover
so you see
uh the the challenges were through put a
number of features we can and the cost
was very high you can see 35
per cell 35 dollars and one dollar even
so
these things can be used but
how you scale it up to the genome wide
you can analyze few cells hundreds and
thousands but how you can million in
trillion cells how can you analyze
that's the aim basically
now if you see then the single cell
platform came initially it was 2008 when
the technology clicked and 2009
basically uh that was manual tank that
page nature paper
then nowadays like whatever's 10x is
using very much drop set and 10x
so you will see the nano droplets
uh drop set
so these are various and the these
things will come again and again so i
will just
go through
so basically drop set
and the 10x i will just explain some of
them
okay
so now
uh there are basically four types one is
the facts fluorescence activated cell
sorting droplet base
nanowarp and none
so if you see here number of cells per
essay you can compare here it is high
actually but
you can see this is basically a very
much widely used in a lot of
publications dropsec and the chromium
10x technology so you can see here they
are basically pretty high not at the
topmost but
they are used and they are droplet based
so i will explain you some of these
concepts
uh here it is just these methods so what
is the flow it will come again and then
so let me just move to the next slide it
will come how it is done
uh it is another comparison slide if you
see in drop set so
here you can see umi and full length so
some are um i in full length some are
not able to full length and the just
three prime end or something like that
um
just
so what are the challenges before we go
to
some of the technology
you know technically explaining the top
things now one first one is cell
isolation how you
isolate the cell it may
you know change the behavior of the cell
like magnetic or by mechanical force or
by enzymatically so that will change the
course of the
your cell it may change the behavior so
that is the one challenge another one is
the amplification because you are at a
single cell so it is very small material
so how this amplification is done that
is another challenge and the throughput
how you increase to you know thousands
and thousands and million cells how can
you so high throughput so these are the
basically the major three challenges
cell isolation amplification and
parallel processing how can do various
steps so that you can bring down the
cost time
and
on the same time increase the throughput
sorry i got back now next challenge is
sensitivity versus
[Music]
sensitive versus
how you can have the
quality
and quantity so now if you see smartsec
it is manual here you can cover
you know genes
i will show you the matrix but here you
will drop some of the genes like you
know the features but this is high
throughput
now the next challenge is
basically at the data level
so if you see the major problem is
dropout events other one is because of
dispersion biological dispersion because
they are very different types of cells
may be there then high magnitude
outliers may be there
but if you see this is the one of the
challenge because when you see the
matrix which will come expression matrix
it is lot of zeros
so it is very sparse and your gene may
be expressing but it may be dropped out
that is the another challenge how to
meet and minimize
that
particular problem
so uh with this kind of introduction and
challenges and why it is needed let me
get through the steps
how it is done single cell sequencing so
the first step is cell isolation so
there are you can see here you can see
here there are various ways so you can
have you know manual
you can have fluorescence activated cell
sorting here then you have
you can have uh antibody based
immunopanning
then you can have a magnetic based
then laser
capture micro dissection and then micro
fluids which is dark set and widely used
so let me
take one which is 10x and chromium they
are using this is
microfluids
now here are two types this is
dropship
if you see here
and he's this is high throughput the
another one is targeted
and that is specs
smart set
two
so let me take this high throughput
here this is a basic flow so first
through the laser you have separated the
cells then this is drop set and or in
drop this is 10x chromium
or
smart set as on previous slide i have
shown
this is less throughput but both the
ends are sequenced so you can do more
things but
the throughput is less here if you see
here only the three prime end is
sequenced and you can detect some of the
gene expression and things like that so
this is the basically basic flow
now these are the steps and i will
explain you each one of them in little
more detail so first you have a cell i
told you
then you disassociate with the cell
isolation which i have shown you on the
previous slide then this is the drop set
so your cell comes and your this is the
droplets
beads
and they will encapsulate your cells
so some are waste
like empty it will go this is also one
another problem and you know people are
trying to minimize this
the but
the thing is your cell is come with the
b
and once it is isolated your left then
you have to license then you have to put
a barcode on next slide i will explain
you once you have done the barcode your
library is prepared and then it goes for
the sequencing and once sequencing is
done as i told you in ngs then you get a
faster q file
of pure
remember as i told in the player example
now you see various tags umi barcode and
you will see the other tags
so these texts are used later to
segregate cell wise or transcript wise
that is the basically a main crux so
this is the drop set which i have told
you now if you see just i will i would
like to
you know explain you how is this
uh droplet works so if you see this is
the bead
basically then it has you can see pcr
handle cell barcode and
unique molecular identifier basically it
will catch your transcript
so this is the droplet now it has
hydrogels and primers it is packed with
this this bead then when cell comes here
then
your
when you lyses them this is your mrna
transcripts they will get attached to
them
right
so you have three handles now pcr handle
cell so you can segregate self from this
and um i basically you can sketch these
particular things so if you have cell
one two three four and then your library
is prepared so that's the way in a
droplet base the b
the sorry droplets are formed and how
they capture your transcripts basically
now this is
that first a i have explained you this
is the beat now if you remember how you
generate basically bar codes so you can
generate
there are different uh ways like
combinatorics and things like that so 12
basis you can generate so month
and 8 basis for umi remember these are
tags
unique tags so this is the way how it is
explained like how many which is around
65 k
so you can analyze you can take so many
cells
right
and the next one
a this is the full flow whatever i
explained so you take your cells in your
drop then you get
you know captured your
cells with the bead then the mrna
is
again i'm repeating just for sake of you
know understanding the full
process then it is attached to it once
it is attached here these are called
stems then you can do pcr and then after
sequencing you get the file
first active file your reads
now when you get a fast accu file it
will your reads will come like this
after sequencing then you have two
barcodes cell barcode in umi
and this is anyway your sequence
now based on barcode cell barcode you
can segregate
your transcripts
in cell and based on your
uh umis you can the finally your matrix
gene expression matrix
for each gene you have a cell then you
will have a count how many so cell one
say like you have three
so
in like you have a here are the genes so
you can see some of the genes here for
example
you have this and you have this here so
it is expressing in cell 1 and it is not
expressing it is there the transcript is
there that we have to see whether it is
expressing or not so finally what you
get is the
expression
matrix
which is different if you remember
expression matrix let me
explain on the next slide
so
we have come to the expression matrix so
so far what i have
uh basically explained is
what is the single cell protocols
right now if we apply this is a single
cell rna-seq you might have heard a lot
now if you see why it is needed if you
have a tissue
now it is a bulk expression and here it
is cell wise expression as i already i
told you like why it is needed when your
cell specific expression is needed in
certain answering some
some of the biological questions so it
is very important in certain situation
now if you look at the
rna-seq bulk rna-seq our matrix
expression matrix was
like this
we have genes and then we have samples
you know so we were telling okay disease
sample non-disease normal sample whether
this gene is expressing or not but we
were not talking about the cell but if
you see in the you know
single cell here you have a gene
then you have cells so in this cell
basically this gene is not there by the
cell so these are the cells
cell 2 which are responsible for dna
expression so now we can
basically specify like these transcripts
in particular gene and these are the
cells responsible so please see
carefully the difference in whatever
your expression matrix comes and this
will go down the line for the analysis
so they are the basically the four steps
in single cell rna sequencing let me
tell you the first one is the sample
preparation which i think we have
already
uh i have already talked about it first
this aggregation of cell isolation and
remove separating them mechanically
enzymatically
or filtering whatever way various ways
are there then you get the single cell
then you use facts droplets and
nanowalls
once you have got the cells and
like i have shown you the
droplets then you add the barcode cell
barcode now i hope you understand what
is um in cell barcode which are helping
to segregate your transcripts and cells
from where it is come now you can have
segmentation or fragmentation pcr then
library like preparation which is three
prime or five prime or it can be full
because this is 10x and they are the
other protocols 10x only
you know sequence the three prime end
then you sequence it can be parent or
single end mostly the parent nowadays
because the cost has come down
now the third step is once as i told you
you get the file
then you de-multiplex it cell wise
then you align to the reference genome
and then you get the matrix
then after that you can have the various
analysis here
that i will show you down the line a few
of them in curate when i will say the
arc port
so this is the basic flow
of rna sequencing now in the data
analysis down you can
special
tissue reconstruction yes that is done
from the sequencing in fact from scr nsf
see what it is doing then you can do
clustering in marker identification
uh what is the expressions are happening
then you can have a dimensional
reduction and see the cells the another
one is you can see on the timeline how
the trajectories of your cells how they
are propagating
in pseudo time
so these are the various analysis can be
done with your single cell data analysis
now in summary we can say once you have
as a bioinformatician you have
expression matrix which are cell versus
gene remember this is not sample versus
gene as in bulk then you have a feature
selection yes you have to sort out you
know what are the differentially
expressed and you know that's why you
can see some is which may not be useful
you have to check it out then
dimensionality reduction and after that
you can see cell cell distance you can
see various things especially map them
or cluster them and
networks and all that kind of things can
be done
now this is all flow which i have
explained
so to add to that the previous slide
this is the full flow slide then you can
have differential expressions then you
can have cell cell interaction networks
you might have seen in various nature in
other papers
then you can have associated association
association with sample phenotypes
what healthy was it disease what are the
cells and then you can have regulatory
networks
now
i have uh done so far the single cell
rnac now i will show you the basic uh
you know various technologies and
protocols for spatial single cell this
is the basic thing in emerging area i
think very much again just to see the
analogy now the picture is the perfect
if you take your picture of your house
then you know where is what right so the
picture is the best
um for a special location but the
problem is you cannot take picture of
all the rna and old genome white
and this is like you know face
or
inside to hybridization or fluorescence
base but
what we are looking at the genome white
means can we cover the whole genome now
if you do the sequencing we are lost
like we have taken from here and fill in
a box that's what you have taken the
cells and you lose the from where it
came
so what is the one basic method can be
done you take them
basically now another barcode will come
which is especially in tissue section so
we can put another tag
and once they are mixed now i can locate
from my tissue if i have a section so i
have say for example this or this i know
from where it came
so that is the one of the idea how the
special
uh sequence mapping is done basically in
single cells so we take especially and
then we can
infer them
now this is timeline so if you see many
here 10x chromium uh they are basically
droplets um inside to capture
technologies mixture then you see lot of
like this is
america's or
basically sec face these are amazing
based so if you see the green ones
so
um
like if you see here in there some are
sequencing based like
star map
and uh like tom said uh there's geosec
here
so
uh
basically four or five types of uh you
know uh
spatial mapping technologies and they
have a some good some bad nothing is
ideal
so
this is a very cluttered slide
um just to check um
yes i'm there everybody is there hello
sonalika
hello
yes sir yes
yeah you are there with me right
okay
yeah good and i hope you are following
right
okay fine so
now if you see the special analysis this
is bit cluttered slide but it has
everything and i will
take slices of it to explain but let me
show you the whole
uh view
so we have a these are the imaging based
if you see the first top left
and then high throughput cell sequencing
waste and then these are the hybrid like
you take amazing profile like sewerage
it takes the um str in a sec and it
takes the
imaging profile uh basically the face
and
then it can reconstruct
so the these are various kind of like in
terms of if you see even bulk rna is
used not even single cell and then you
have the somehow the special data uh
triangulated in
you know that information is embedded to
that this kind of technology so there
are various emerging technologies which
are using bulk rna and from
you know that cell atlas or somewhere it
is given and then how to merge integrate
data or use the drop set and uh scrna
sec data and isc face or some imaging
data and they re reconstruct the spatial
location of those cells
so
now if we
the basically there are four types
one is in silico as i told you they take
the rna sequencing scrna and the fish
data
and they try to
re
map it
especially now but cannot match
coordinate intent to simplify basically
that's what simplify and you get that
kind of thing the next one is laser
capture micro dissection in that
you have a limitation
this is few cells you can do then inside
you this is an imaging based
so you have phase or various four or
five times four five types are there
and then you have a rna imaging this is
also i think pretty much emerging
detects only targeted transcripts so
everyone has a good
and some bad
pros and cons now if you look at it the
four types i have told you so first you
take rna-seq it's just a flow to just
show you in the image the previous slide
it explodes the previous slide and then
you have it inside to hybridization
and then uh there is a suret here which
is hidden behind it now it will
basically you can take this part and
integrate with this
and it is very easy pipeline in cirrit
in fact you can explore it the next one
is basically the lcm sec and geosec
based
there you can see it is a sequencing
based uh using the barcodes
and the third one it is amazing based
basically
this is uh
murphy's
which is basically
multiplex error robust fish
this is also pretty much
you know used
so this is imaging based and the next
one the last one fourth one is you can
see here special ids the bar codes are
added you take the slices and you add
the bar codes and then sequence
so basically the four types the one
computational methods first one lcm
based then rna amazing and then i inside
the sequencing methods so
four types of now there are two things
we have talked about one is you have a
single cell sequencing here
the other part which i have
shown you this is special
so now a
good amount of challenges how you can
integrate this data you will see a lot
of papers and how so that you can better
infer
the
biology whatever the questions you are
inferring if you
these two things how they can be merged
and there is the various you know
technologies if you see here lcm
so if you see the gene measured are very
high but if you see the x-axis cells
and this is gene measured okay
throughput of cells or spots so now if
you see they are very good in
sensitivity they can measure genes but
you can analyze only very less cells
but if you see the other
they are pros and cons and these some
are just computational based
these are the algorithms here you can
see
in the other many if you are seeing
these things there are imaging based
nerf is four five six it is evolving
so uh all kind of these technologies
with plus miners and that kind of thing
various things are there
and this is the
barcoding strategy which i'm not going
to go into deep but
uh various phase sm phase nerf is and
that kind of thing of the bar coding as
i have explained you
now what we have done so far to
summarize we did the bulk
rna set then we have a single cell and
we got the
you see here we got the gene and sample
wise and then here we got the matrix
then we have a special section we have
taken and
we have mapped
either through imaging or through
computationally we have reconstructed
the tissue
sections with the cell mapping so we
have covered these three things
okay now
let me get to the single cell
epigenetics sc 80 asap because it's the
simple one and it is adapted
for the single cell analysis there are
chipseq and other protocols now when you
look at the epigenetic profile you have
a three regions basically if you have
the chromatin accessibility then you
have a protein dna interactions then you
have a dna methylation basically like in
cancer and things like that now if you
see for chromatin
accessibility you have mnas dnas pyramid
and new one which is atic which is
essays for transposes accessible
chromatin and i'm going to cover this
one for the epigenetics which is adapted
basically for the single cell and i will
let it give you the tools and things
like that now if here is the comparison
all
uh basically the chromatin accessibility
the first chipset
that also you can use dna's at set and
mr
mnas and pirate now if you can see here
no sonification is needed as it is
needed here it is just endonuclease
tn5 then you have a segmentation
so this is just a comparison slides of
various uh you know things and in fact
they are not exclusive they help each
other you cannot answer all the
questions with one protocol
basically so what is athc this is for
transposes accessible chrome maintain so
it will
give you what is the chromat chromatin
is accessible as you know that is what
is the regulation happens so you have it
this is basically uh not
what you say like mutated kind of
transposes nucleus 5 and it is like a
cut and paste when it comes it will cut
and paste your fragment here
and that it will segmentation so it will
basically like capturing your accessible
chromatin once it comes so you have
barcode primers
here
and then you can see we have got that
segment we can filter and take it out
then we amplify and then you put
barcodes whatever
you know this bar codes and umi's are
very important to later access the
particular
information or the segment what then it
goes to the next generation sequencing
so basically you can use this
um
i'm not talking about single cell it is
basically a normal even normal
now if if you in a layman language if
you can tag you can take a single cell
chromatic
and then you can have the like a crnsk
you can tag single cell here then again
you can do the similar thing as we have
done in single cell rnac
now what does the prone
pros of this it is very fast in fact
simple and sensitive you can see three
hours otherwise it takes days and it
works on many cell types
and requires no sonification phenol
chloroform
like pyrite you and antibodies you know
these all processes and chipseek or
firearms
they create the bias
and
the the last thing which is it is
modified for single cell analysis
which it is very difficult for the other
that's why you see 10x chromatin
uh they have used this protocol the
other cones is basically it is cells
must be optimized if you have two less
and two high cells it won't give the
good performance and you can do all kind
of uh some of these uh you know
epigenetics analysis nuclear mapping
transcription factor occupancy
identification of novel enhancers in
deep study of the genomic profiles
so
this is somewhat um
you can see in a picture basically what
i have explained so here is ata sec and
then after that you can
see the picture now sorry peaks
here and on the with your reference
genome so you can see where it is
binding uh
basically where it is binding your
enhancer in something like
this kind of questions you can answer
like suppose it is a healthy your here
is your binding your enhancer and
suppose the mutation happens it doesn't
bind okay so you can address such
disease whether see it is epigenetics
and whether it is binding or not binding
so that kind of
questions you can answer with this kind
of protocol
what some of the things i'm telling you
can do many other things basically
now
uh till here uh we have 10 minutes let
me i think we will be able to finish
so
i have covered quite a few things uh
three four things now there are tools
right you have sewer monocle and snappy
one tool i have taken there are many
actually so i will explain you quickly
what can be done with these tools and
how they work
in fact this uret was the first and very
famous and it is used so basically what
they do they demultiplex and read
alignment
and uh not this unit it is done by cell
ranger that next slide i will explain
then basically they will quantify
and data filter and data normalize once
they normalize then you can see the
reads and cells that matrix comes once
you get that matrix you can do so you
see here genes and cells then you can do
pca you map
t sign it
you know reduction you can have
hierarchical clustering and then you
have marker genes detection
right differentially expressed genes in
which cells and things basically this is
what mostly and then you have a monocle
3 which gives you the dynamic gene
expression in inference the trajectories
rna velocity basically
so the flow is the first part
as you know i have told you the pasta q
file you get from the sequencer then you
have align cell barcode and umi counting
is done then you get the matrix
this is the very computationally
intensive process
and you need a big machines and the cell
ranger will give you this and i think
it's freely available then you can use
it then once you get the feature barcode
matrix then you can do
cell identification as already we have
talked different types of cell you can
have trajectories
and you can have the differentially
expressed genes so you see right here
monocular 3 and curette can do this in
fact this surat has for
atsx single cell analysis also they have
incorporated in fact it is evolving they
are adding
day by day new features whatever we have
explained the five six dimensions so if
you see insurance even
the analysis of special data sets you
see they map if you have availability of
a spatial data set it can be mapped to
your single cell or any sequencing data
or chipset data
then you can do other things like
quality rna differential gene
expressions
and
the next one is monoplay there you can
see basically the trajectory it came
and this is a snap atac that
i won't show you in the running but here
you can see the main part are others are
normalization even you see in chipset
but the differentiating part for single
cell is you have the clustering cell
wise and this is the basically the main
part peak calling
where is the binding is happening rest
is the different analysis you can see
pseudo time and everything once it you
have a data single cell you can
run on anything
so now let me give you a quick demo
okay
so
hello everybody is there
hello
yes sir yes yes go ahead we are
following yes sir yes so
i will just quickly share the another
screen
so
um
[Music]
so basically this is the re studio
and easily you can you know build
are you able to see my screen this
hello can you see my code
yes sir yes sir yes you can see us
called kodi so this is the basically let
me show you the first sewer it
was run
just to save time
so basically how quickly let me show
first you take the sewerage and this is
the r studio you can install
i'm on
ubuntu 20.04
so
these are the some of the libraries
which are used by it and it will tell so
let me run it step by step okay
so these are and then package sewerage
if you are aware of the r and the
packages
so easily and if you go in tools here
and you say install packages
and uh you can just type here suret
and it will come just click and say
install is not that but you may
uh stuck in some dependencies uh then
you have to resolve them
[Music]
basically i have to go to the code
directory so
fine
then
first read the data and
let me tell you this data i have
downloaded it is already data in that
site and it comes from the cell ranger
10x data
library and
this is like that matrix bar course umis
and there are three files basically
which is going to use so
we have taken the data now
it has one three seven one four features
you can you can look at it here
if you look at it here it is showing the
output here what is going to come in
the figures will come in the right panel
then
so now you can
see here
like uh zoom plot
your data here so different kind of
like various things you can plot
okay
so
let me see the other these are just
features of how your data is scattered
and things like that
then the first step you have to
normalize the data and you can use
various methods if you just see the help
on this you have different parameters so
the first step is after first step read
the data which is from 10x cell ranger
it comes just to summarize the you know
the steps then here basically the here
you normalize the data
once it is normalized
then
you have find variable features
basically it will find
your
like
genes and features and that
then you can see that
let me just plot and i can show you
[Music]
something like this so
variance average expression it will
show
then after that um
you have to scale the data
just to you know
it will take a while it is done then
you have to do the dimension reduction
linear this is pca or
um it supports all here is a pca you can
say you map also so it will support
those
various dimensional you know reductions
then you can plot this is pca see here
it is pca here
okay
which i have highlighted you can have
umap and so it will show you different
pc1 and pc2 it is showing two principal
components if you are aware like you
know dimensional reductionality the
first two three components of principal
component analysis they give you most of
the data that's the idea actually it's
something like you have a lot of data
and you have segregated the main data
into the one corner of your room suppose
it is scattered on your house on the
floor then you choose what is the
important and pile up in the one corner
in a layman language i am telling you
principle component analysis is
something like that so it will your
important you know information it will
in first two three components it will
segregate that's the dimensional
reductionality okay
then you can see the heat map these are
just you know
this is pc earlier you saw the different
plot it is a different plot
then you have the another heat map like
you know
so you can see the various ways
um
this was giving
okay
i want to show you the
umap just wait a while it is processing
it takes time
so now you can see here now you have got
your cells basically eight types
so this is umap
right
uniform manifold approximation and
projection
if you are aware of that and mainly the
you may have insinity you map is in some
cases
it works better than sanity so
now you have eight clusters basically
these are the clusters you can see the
clusters eight clusters here then you
can see the cells here
the next one
now
that is the differential gene expression
it has shown the head if you uh
you know
no here let me highlight with the mouse
this one you can see it has given you
the basically these are the markers they
are calling it do not differential
basically the markers so you see the
gene list here then you see the lock fc
p values like you have seen in a bulk
rna seek and the cell wise it will be
so
basically that's what he's doing now
there are eight clusters in markers the
gene it basically it is attaching the
genes now you can see the genes
differentially expressed genes so there
are eight clusters
uh
five six seven eight so
uh i think we i can show this only in
two more minutes
i think we are running out of time
anyway we started five minutes late
hello sonalika do i have still time
yes sir please go ahead yes sir please
go ahead
so another five minutes let i want to
show you the trajectory also
so uh
now you can see here uh if you see the
code we we have given uh you know
we have given two genes here
cd79a and ms4 a1 now you see the
expression of label in the which cluster
it is you see that in the cluster 3 and
here in this so you can see the gene and
you can see the cells in that cluster
cell wise clusters so you can see that
this gene basically if you infer the
information so this is the gene and you
will find the cluster of cells like this
is the cluster number three now this
gene is expressing in that cluster so
that's the way you infer that where the
genes are which kind of cells that gene
is being expressed now if you see the
code here
we have given these two genes and then
again he is giving the another gene here
and
okay
[Music]
so this is the another cells now
sorry genes now if you see here in the
it is expressing
nkf7 in the fourth cluster very high
remember the clusters are cell specific
so now you can find
how they so here if you see
this pf4
basically the cluster eight these cells
are responsible
for the majorly expression of pf4
that's what we wanted to find out
right
so
that's what
you can get now here
uh you can see
you know the other
heat maps means various ways that is the
violent plot now you can see the
you have the clusters here i will show
you the uh one so now you see any
particular gene you can take this one so
you can see this is in this particular
cluster so like that you can see the
heat map like this particular gene is
here this type of cells in here l y z
here and how much is the other place
expression majorly these cells but it is
expressing in this so
now uh i think you can realize like how
um
we can get the cell specific information
uh from these data um
right
so
cell identity clusters
so you have genes and then you have the
fourth now you can see which genes are
where how they are expressing right the
top zero one two they are say eight
clusters in the other side so what i i
want to demonstrate you that most of
them the things which i have talked
about is just naming the you know cells
you can see here so different cell types
uh clusters eight clusters and you can
see i know b b cells nk cells and
cd4 t
like that so whatever i taught you in
the
uh basically in the presentation now you
can see most of the things coming here
right
and
[Music]
monoplay i'll just run source it fully
and i want to show you the basic you can
have
you know trajectories
it takes a while
i can take questions by the time it the
window will come if you have any
please go ahead if any one of you are
having
some query some question you can reach
me later also let me write my email id
you can take
s
gmail.com that is my id you can
you know reach me any tool or anything
you are
please let me have any questions you
have
or anything else
whatever i have covered so far now one
window will come i will select one cell
and show you the pseudo trajectory
that's it
it takes a while
let it come
anybody has any question or
would like to ask something specific
hello everybody is there
hello
sonalika
hello yes sir yes sir we are here we are
here there is a question that came out
from zara commerce uh and the question
is can we use uret analysis for
bacterial cells
uh yes i think you can yes sir am i
audible to you yes i'm
yes you are
yes please go ahead
yes basically you can use there is a
i don't think in fact the data what i
have taken is uh it is some bacterial
data only
uh the example what i am showing you
uh
bacterial or
some i think brain but yes you can use
in fact they have the data example data
for it
and there is one more question related
to siri professor and daniel asks what
package uh
or what library
is similar to suret that can be used in
python environment
um
actually i am not sure about python
because
i hardly work on that but
[Music]
i am not sure actually but i don't know
whether cirit can be used on python or
not
but
i have no idea actually i don't work in
python
but i'm sure i think there must be
adaptation with rappers
maybe offline i can answer if you don't
find or i can tell you some package
which is used in python if you approach
me
but right now
um
i have no idea actually in python
whether it works or not or the other
packages
thank you thank you professor and i'm
looking for any other queries
please type in your questions in the
chat box i will read it out to professor
okay there is a question from
radhakrishnan and the question is how is
the cell sorting done using
microfluidics
is it confirmed or validated and how can
we know which cell type is where
okay
so
for that
so let me finish this i need to go to i
have you know briefly covered that
uh how then droplets basically
uh okay
so just one second let me so here the
screen has come so you can choose
basically which one trajectory you want
this has learned the graph basically so
for example if i take this so you have
to take the start one so i have taken
the start and one i am taking
so i have done now once it it is taken
all right
so
if you have taken this is the trajectory
sudo time so i started here if you
remember i marked it here
multiple cells
now how it is
so the basic you can refine it in fact
much more refined it gives when you set
the parameters but this is the way you
can see the trajectory
in the monocle 3 this is monocle 3.
with this
let me come to that question so
basically what happens in the droplet
you
let me
let me stop this
[Music]
so if you go to that to answer that
question
i hope you are able to see my ppt again
yes sir
so
basically
i just
so here this is a actually microfluidic
device
so from one side
the cells are pumped and the other side
the beads are basically in the oil and
it encapsulates the cells inside the
bead
it can miss also
so the basically whatever it has
encapsulated
like you can see there is a one beat one
cell type this is cell this is b
the another cell so different types of
cells and beats are coming that's the
way it encapsulate
the cell in a bead basically remember
the bead this is micro particle it has
all the
basically the primers and tags and once
it takes to it then only you can
recognize down the line so
here if you see
first you take
you know
no this is basically these are like stem
single cell transcriptomes attached to
micro particles
and there can be a miss
like for example if you see once they
are isolated
and i have shown you the isolation
mechanism it can be enzymatic or here it
is through the this droplets so now if
you see this is the only useful single
cell this is the one of the problem
where we miss the many cells so if you
see here only this is it has captured
with the b itself this is an empty
droplet it has to be discarded and it
has taken multiple it has to be also
discarded because later you cannot find
from this cell that's come so it misses
now the miss rate is less early it was
high so that's the way
the in the droplets basically you want
to get this attached this transcriptome
to this which has the primers
and
like if you see here and that's the way
it is
catch when something you miss it is miss